warnung vor boards tod bei medikamenten
versuch videobeweis für spezielle
wolkenart und der antibiotika ja oder
nein schnelltest das sind vier der fünf
themen in den krieg zum 250 im rahmen
einer klinischen studie für ein neues
schmerzmittel in frankreich ist ein
proband vermutlich an dem verabreichten
medikament gestorben eine untersuchung
ergab dass er einem hirntod erlag
außerdem sollen noch weitere probanden
der studie in lebensgefahr schweben sie
werden derzeit im krankenhaus behandelt
die folgen für die vier betroffenen
können gravierende schäden am gehirn
seien berichtete der chef neurologe am
sonntag universitaire de ren
die studie wurde von dem unternehmen bio
trial durchgeführt und vom
portugiesischen pharmakonzern wie all in
auftrag gegeben was genau bei der
medikamentenstudie schief gelaufen ist
ist noch nicht ganz geklärt zitat
derzeit befinden wir uns weiter im
rahmen von unvorhersehbar ungeklärten
und unerklärlichen ereignissen so france
prozess der geschäftsführer von bio
trial das in raum getestete medikament
mit einem wirkstoff des
pharmaherstellers ball befand sich nach
angaben des französischen
gesundheitsministeriums in der ersten
testphase in der der wirkstoff in
kleinen dosen am menschen getestet wird
zitat dieser wirkstoff zielt auf die
behandlung von stimmungs und
angststörungen sowie motorischen
störungen die mit neurodegenerativen
erkrankungen verknüpft sind erklärte die
gesundheitsministerin frankreichs war
ich soll
tura ob der ganze vorfall als unfall
eingestuft werden kann oder ob dann noch
mehr dahinter steckt das soll jetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft klären die die
ermittlungen bereits aufgenommen hat
videobeweis für spezielle wolkenart seit
2006 versucht die cloud appreciation
society eine neue wolken art in die
datenbank der weltorganisation für
meteorologie kurz damit zubringen die
wolkenart und lars peters wurde zwar
schon mal von meteorologen beobachtet
aber bis jetzt nicht in den
internationalen wolkenatlas aufgenommen
die letzte aktualisierung ist jetzt auch
schon ein bisschen her der letzte wolken
hat das wurde 1987 veröffentlicht und
die letzten wolken arten wurden 1951
registriert was die neue wolken hat
besonders macht beschreibt andreas macke
vom leibniz institut für
troposphärenforschung so zitat wir
beobachten eine raue strukturierte
wolken unterkante zitat ende im
gegensatz dazu sind herkömmliche wolken
eher flach und du latus als pirat es ist
eher selten und wenn man sie entdeckt
dann am ehesten in den usa dennoch soll
die wolkenart noch dieses jahr in den
wolkenatlas aufgenommen werden es soll
eine digitale auflage erscheinen wie die
wolke hat aussieht das seht ihr jetzt in
einem kleinen ausschnitt eines videos
den link zum ganzen video findet ihr wie
immer in der video beschreibung
der antibiotika ja oder nein schnelltest
schon oft haben wir über die risiken
einer antibiotika resistenz berichtet
immer wieder stößt man auf das problem
mit dieser eigentlich vermeidbaren
resistenz denn viel zu viele menschen
nehmen antibiotika ein obwohl es in
vielen fällen gar nicht notwendig wäre
dadurch entstehen resistenzen gegen das
medikament den dringenden fällen zum
beispiel einer lungenentzündung kann das
dann lebensgefährlich werden wenn die
mittel keine wirkung mehr zeigen
ein neuer bluttest soll es ärzten nun
ermöglichen schnell und richtig zu
handeln patienten die auf einer
behandlung mit antibiotika bestehen
würden könnten so auch schneller von
einer anderen behandlungsweise überzeugt
werden der test soll es ermöglichen in
relativ kurzer zeit also ungefähr einer
stunde zu klären ob eine bakterielle
oder eine virale infektion vorliegt im
falle einer virusinfektion hilft eben
ein antibiotikum nicht im fachmagazin
science translational medicine berichten
experten über den test und seine
funktionsweise sowohl bakterien als auch
virus zellen haben eine eigene
handschrift die so genannte gen signatur
anhand dieser wie man aus machen welche
infektion bei einem patienten vorliegt
bei essen versuchen konnte man mit dem
neuen test eine 87 prozentige
treffsicherheit erzielen bisher wird ein
procalcitonin pct für die bestimmung
eingesetzt der liegt nur der zu 78
prozent richtig der direktor des
zentrums für infektionsmedizin und
krankenhaushygiene am uniklinikum jena
matthias plätze sieht die
forschungsergebnisse so zitat das
verfahren bietet einen blick in die
zukunft zitat ende
die sinnlose einnahme von antibiotika
könnte sobald deutlich reduziert werden
infektionsrisiko minimiert dank
implantat ein großes problem der
chirurgie ist das risiko von infektionen
für patienten besteht dieses risiko
nicht nur während der operation sondern
auch noch nach dem eingriff die gefahr
einer infektion und damit auch die
daraus resultierenden folgen lassen sich
jedoch reduzieren forscher in den usa
haben im fachmagazin nature
zukunftsweisenden forschungsergebnisse
dazu veröffentlicht den patienten soll
ein sensor implantiert werden der
schwellungen und infektionen melden
sollen zitat das ist eine neue klasse
biobio medizinischer implantate so john
rogers von der university of illinois in
urbana-champaign dieses biomedizinische
implantat soll herkömmliche
implantierbare messinstrumente ersetzen
mit solchen instrumenten überwacht man
patienten nach herzerkrankungen oder
beispielsweise schlaganfällen schlagen
die messinstrumente alarm kann zeitnah
eingegriffen und eine im verborgenen
liegen die infektion verhindert werden
zitat das ziel ist ein gerät das in das
gehirn oder in andere organe implantiert
wird eng mit dem betreffenden organ
verbunden ist und drahtlose signale
übermittelt welche informationen zum
zustand des organs liefern damit erste
bei bedarf eingreifen können um größere
probleme zu vermeiden berichtet nadine
murphy von der washington university in
saint louis
die derzeit eingesetzten messinstrumente
bringen allerdings selbst das risiko
einer infektion mit sich das jetzt neu
entwickelte biomedizinischen platz
setzte sich nach wenigen tagen von
selbst und stellt somit keine
infektionsgefahr an sich mehr da der
sensor selbst und auch die platine auf
der befestigt ist
die sind so gefertigt dass der
menschliche organismus diese innerhalb
von etwa drei tagen abbauen kann
siliziumdioxid nanoporöse silizium und
politik akt litogo zieht das sind die
stoffe aus dem die teile für den sensor
gefertigt werden kleiner wermutstropfen
der sensor kann zwar schon ratlos
informationen übertragen allerdings
benötigt er dazu bauteile die der körper
nicht vollständig zu ersetzen kann
nichtsdestotrotz blicken die experten
optimistisch in die zukunft zitat wir
glauben
das ist in der nahen zukunft möglich
sein wird therapeutische funktion wie
die elektrische stimulation oder die
gabe von medikamenten in solche systeme
einzubetten und war bei den
entscheidenden bio resorbierbaren
charakter zu bewahren das sagte rogers
der traum auf einem board einem cover
bord über dem boden zu schweben
das kennt man aus zurück in die zukunft
ja aber ganz so weit ist die technik
leider noch nicht es gibt dennoch hafer
boards mit rädern die sieht man immer
häufiger und die sind inzwischen ein
beliebtes fortbewegungsmittel solange
der akku hält allerdings sieht die
amerikanische aufsichtsbehörde consumer
product safety commission cpsc in den
akkus eine gefahr ihn zur folge sondern
immer einen feuerlöscher griffbereit
haben okay das ist beim fahren etwas
schwer aber es geht auch er um den
lagerbetrieb einige cover boards
teilweise importe aus china sollen schon
beim ladevorgang in flammen aufgegangen
sein dazu kommt noch boards die
angeblich von den underwriters
laboratories getestet wurden lagen
überhaupt die haben die sind nicht von
dieser vereinigung geprüft worden
das wäre dann auch noch eine falsche
angabe auf den produkten die cpsc möchte
jetzt klären was mit den akkus nicht
stimmt warum diese häufig probleme
machen und ob es noch weitere
sicherheits bestimmungen bezüglich der
hammer bots geben sollte der chef der
scb scl uk denkt da zum beispiel an für
notebook-akkus vergleichbare bestimmung
wichtige infos an alle die hier in
deutschland auf cover bodrum fahren hier
in deutschland sind diese boards weder
auf straßen noch auf gehwegen zugelassen
nur auf privatgrund ist das fan erlaubt
frage an euch würdet ihr zum anderen
thema euch medikamententests zur
verfügung stellen oder habt ihr angst
vor den folgen lasst es uns in den
kommentaren wissen ich bin auf die
antworten gespannt und vergesse nicht
den kanal achtung kostenlos zu
abonnieren schaut das nächste video ist
wie immer spannend und yahya bis dann
bleibt dran